when you start a company and you're on
boarding you know you're really happy
you're engaged you're having
but then somewhere along the line you
know the engagement starts
to lag welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring upwards labs and
hillel at stanford
this episode is all about work the
future of work
meet paris petgrave episode 290
co-founder and ceo of we love work
an app which helps companies build
happier more resilient teams by solving
the recruitment engagement and retention
problems
she has worked as a consultant and built
products and services for a number of
large
multinational organizations including
barclays harrods virgin mastercard and
nhs
in 2017 she was listed as the top 100 em
power leaders in the financial times
and a rising star in the power list of
2018 and 2019.
paris petgrave thank you so much for
joining me how are you today
i'm great thank you for having me all
the way from london i'm i'm very lucky
to have you we're going to have such a
fun conversation about
about the meaning of work you're the ceo
of we love work
but we actually found out that we have a
kind of an interesting background
together
i'm calling from tel aviv and you
actually spent quite some time dealing
with the israeli ecosystem so tell me
about that
oh my goodness it was it was actually
one of the major things that um
inspired me guess what i've read you
know the book um before i
before i started real of work i read
startup nation obviously
if you don't know the book you must read
startup nation
so i was always intrigued about israel
um
basically from a historical standpoint
and
you know from this whole culture that
you have in in you know the kind of
machine
for startups and i was so lucky this was
way back in like 2013
um to get to meet you know john medved
and
obviously if you guys don't know he's a
pioneering
investor in in in israel who set up an
amazing
um crowdfunding platform probably one of
the first to be honest and um
i used to i used to bring um groups of
investors over to israel for a brilliant
kind of
um you know tour of the ecosystem
along with a lovely holiday because
obviously if you haven't had a chance to
visit israel
stunningly beautiful a lovely place to
visit
you know it's got so many amazing
attractions on a tourist
level and yeah i was just amazed at
how you know the ecosystem worked
how you know from a very young age i
mean from university age
you know tech talents like properly head
hunted and
you know incubated so i was able to see
you know all of these different
incubators and how you know people came
up with ideas
and how ideas were cultivated and how
you know entrepreneurship
so much promoted so much celebrated
and it was very exciting and it was a
very early stage of the kind of
ecosystem as well in terms of what
john was doing see he's doing wonders
now
um but he's an amazing character he's
one of my
biggest inspirations to be honest he
definitely had an effect on me as an
early kind of founder and not really in
the tech space to be honest
i was just mesmerized by his charisma
and his passion for startups and his
relatability you know we'd have little
bits of chats and you know he's just
very kind of cool guy
and in a very male dominated kind of
very kind of it can be kind of like feel
a bit
or imposter syndrome sometimes for women
in the tech
space i felt very much at home in israel
and um i really did admire that about
the ecosystem
and so that's that's my kind of little
story
i love that and then we have to have one
more fun story before we dive into we
love work which is that you dj for fun
uh i am so terrified of seeing those big
you know boxes with all those with all
those little pads do you enjoy that do
you enjoy
you know making art with that well you
know it's so interesting and again
this is another thing that you know i
got from israel in some ways you know
they have a very amazing dance scene
and yeah we get to visit if you ever get
to visit hopefully we do
you know post covert but you know the
whole kind of tel aviv scene was super
cool and obviously a b
fair and stuff and i visited a few of
those places i was like wow this is so
amazing
you know all these big djs and
everything and i you know i was like
well i need to find a hobby to do
because obviously you know as an
entrepreneur you can sometimes get so
you know sucked into work that even
going to the gym or doing any exercise
you're kind of like oh should i do you
know
like work on business strategy or should
i go for a run you kind of like you know
it's difficult to get that balance so i
must commit to something that i can
learn
that i can do that doesn't affect like
you know that can i can do
in my home um and it gives me a bit of a
challenge and i thought well djing
actually i can buy the equipment and i
can be
in my room on my decks kind of doing
things and it was just
it just seemed like a great opportunity
and i did it i started
doing it not too long ago but over
lockdown it was a godsend because
obviously
it kept me occupied for hours
so i think you know djing is such a fun
thing i think you know if you've got
the space and you invest in the
equipment it's just it's brilliant
because you can make your own music
and you know you can just have fun with
it and you know it's a really good thing
to learn
so i would definitely recommend it as a
great hobby
i love that i i want to pick your brand
on a few different subjects they're all
revolving around
this idea behind we love work so maybe
before i go into those different
verticals can you share with me a little
bit about what you're doing with we love
work
and and how you got to build
this organization yeah definitely
so um i've always kind of been
entrepreneurial my family is very
entrepreneurial and all have their own
businesses and
they were always pushing me to go into
business although i wasn't 100 convinced
because you know you never want to
really want to do what your parents
wanted i do it's not so cool you kind of
want to
go against that so i never really was
fully convinced but you know
you know i got to a certain age and i
was like okay you know i tried a few
different things i tried to rebel a
little bit and
kind of fell into it and i started off
by
um doing some investing and also
um doing building out some companies
around consultancy so we were doing
consultancy i was doing head hunting
i started head hunting for some quite
big major corporations pharmaceutical
companies and so on and you know it was
really
an exciting time and then i was doing um
sort of tech recruitment and head
hunting in like large pharmaceutical
companies and i was doing
a lot around recruitment and one of the
things that i found when i was head
hunting these
you know c-suite execs who were amazing
you know
really like superstars in their
organizations and i was trying to curse
them into another organization
and on some occasions um
you know these brilliant amazing people
i would place them into organizations
and they would just hate it
and they would be like paris this isn't
for me and i'd be like what do you mean
this is an amazing opportunity i got you
like so much more money like
what do you mean you don't like it and
it was always because it wasn't because
they couldn't do the job
it was because of the culture it was
like this is not the right place for me
this isn't the right fit
and obviously you know from a selfish
selfish perspective i was like oh my god
like you know i'm not going to get my
commission what do you mean you want to
leave because obviously
when you're head hunting you have like a
certain period of time the individual
needs to stay and i was like no please
stay a little bit longer
but sometimes it was just so off that
they were just like no
i don't want to ruin my career by
staying here i'm just going to quickly
jump out within the first three months
because then it won't i won't even have
to put it on my cv you know it was a
wrong decision i'm gonna go somewhere
else
and in those times i felt really bad
first of all because obviously they'd
made the transition and it
kind of almost failed and secondly i was
like how can what can we do to solve
this problem
because you know it's not that they
don't have the skills it's not that
they're not superstars and amazing in
their current roles
what is that thing that just makes them
like not be able to
kind of perform or fit in or engage or
just be happy
in that in that specific working
environment and just started to explore
that a lot more and
working with a lot of business
psychologists and started to do a lot of
assessments around
like hiring and stuff we started to um
you know create some methodology around
like measuring culture within
organizations and measuring
values and attitudes and behaviors of
the individuals we're placing in those
organizations and doing that manually
and then an a friend of mine who
actually is very much heavily involved
in the tech
industry was setting up an accelerator
and was talking to me you know they were
saying you know paris what you're doing
is really interesting you should look at
productizing it
and i was like really and they were like
absolutely you should look at
productizing because i think that you
know
there's an opportunity there and i was
like that's so interesting
although i haven't come from a tech
background i was obviously
you know we were doing a lot of it
manually but i could understand you know
the process and the benefits of
productizing because obviously our
challenges were definitely time
constraints and so on
so we started to put to put together a
product and
you know we started to test that product
with our clients we started to get some
traction around that
um and then i guess i just all of a
sudden
became a tech entrepreneur and started
to kind of build a
a team around that and actually um uh
you know raised a pre-seed and went to
the states and
went to an accelerator and you know
engaged in the community and
it was so interesting because in that
kind of in that time a few years before
it was probably about three years before
i was
was working with investors and stuff and
going to israel so i already kind of had
the seed planted
but again you know as a non-technical
founder sometimes you're a bit kind of
skeptical and you're maybe
you know you're maybe a bit fearful or
maybe you have a little bit of you know
imposter syndrome oh can i really do
this
i think it wasn't until like a lot of my
you know techy friends
said look you know i think there's
there's something in this and you should
look at productizing it
they were giving me loads of books like
lean startup and you know i was reading
all about kind of lean methodology and
all this
right and made tons of mistakes like
horrible
horrible mistakes you know i had to
learn
as you know i built so much product
the first stage you know we just built
like so
many features just too much you know we
didn't keep it lean it was i got the
book too late to be honest
on the first leg you just don't think
like that until you talk
you know you know as a tech founder you
you're taught to
you know you know to be lean to get your
customers first to look at your sales
strategy first and so on and so forth
and you know it's really really um it's
really interesting
you know once you kind of get that first
stage and then you're like okay no i'm
gonna do this the right way
and learn how to you know build out your
marketing strategy your go to market
strategy think about your customers and
all the rest of it before you start
building
you know huge amounts of product so
yeah it was been a great learning
experience and
i've been really lucky to have some
amazing people around me to support me
and stuff like that and
you know you're always learning even i
think if you're i think if you're a
technical founder you're learning the
sales piece
for me i would i already had the sales
piece so i was learning the technical
piece
the product piece it's always good to
have a great team around you
and you know navigate but you know it's
the way
it's the future and i think you know
there's going to be so many people going
into entrepreneurship who are
going straight into technology-based
startups you know this
you know because obviously the key thing
now is okay we're going to create an
app we're going to create a product so i
think that
one of the things that i'm that i'm
curious about and i want to hear
more tangibly about what what what we
love work does and
how you work with people in that regard
but first talk to me a little bit about
what it means to have a purpose-driven
career
so you touched on that as a pain point
that you discovered more as a headhunter
and you've noticed that people are not
fulfilled and you're wondering why are
they happy why aren't they satisfied why
are they engaging the way that i would
expect them
because everything on the paper said
that they should be engaging right so
so talk to me a little bit about some of
the insights that you've understood
throughout these years
from your experience about what does it
mean to really
have a purpose-driven career and what
are the different you know
forces that come together to make that
happen yeah i think that's a really good
question
and i think you know one of the things
that you know really made me love
my role as a headhunter is you know the
satisfaction that you get when you
able to support someone and walk them
through you know getting an opportunity
that they're really you know fulfilled
in it's life-changing you know
i think we spend majority of our lives
working you know like when you think
about it for a percentage basis we're at
work
most of the time so that that place
needs to be a happy place it needs to be
a place where you're connected and it
you know so many times you know
obviously you know money is a huge
incentive but it's not necessarily the
bottom line and there's a lot of
research
right now with millennials it's much
more of a purpose-driven thing
and you know that's what's really
attracting people that people want to
work for companies that they
they align from a values perspective you
know
it's not just about the money if you're
not going to be treated fairly or if the
company's not going to care about the
environment of the company's not acting
ethically
there's so much more to the way that
people are choosing and
you know pioneering companies like
glassdoor kind of opened
the the the you know the review space
and now you can actually
you know employ a brand that's that was
a huge thing that came about where
people you know employers now have a
brand
for you know attracting talent so
actually
as an employee you have to be very
conscious about what you're putting out
and how you're you're coming across the
potential talent because
you know the labour market is is
competitive
um you know many people say it's all
about your team and if you've got you
know you've got a players and you've got
the best people you win
that's as simple as that it's all about
people it's all about who you have
and you know so it's highly competitive
and companies have to think about that
and um you know that way culture became
something that was very good and you
know
god rest of soul you know there are so
many pioneering people that you know
really pushed and drove
culture um as a thing because before it
was kind of this wishy-washy thing and
it became
much more of an important thing and
obviously we've seen in the past
three four years how how critically
important it's become we've seen in 2020
how pretty much every single ceo from
the pre-seed stage to the pre-ipo stage
they were tested
with what what they're doing and how
strong is their culture
because it's being tested in times like
these right it's not tested in the happy
hour it's tested
when you know defend and and
now you have to deliver the right
messages and you have to see
how people are responding so i i want to
make sure that we also have enough time
to talk about we love work and
and how you work with with businesses to
really make sure they're they're
drilling down on what's important for
their employees
retention engagement and and really
provide them the skill sets
to not do what you experienced you know
back then so how does that actually how
does this whole thing come together
absolutely so we are you know so
nowadays when we purchase the product
when we when we do when we buy
a meal off ubereats immediately there's
an opportunity for us to
post a review or give feedback you know
when we have a conversation with our
our cell phone provider or when we have
someone come around to deliver a service
immediately we get a ping on our on our
cell phone and they're asking us to
provide feedback now the culture of
feedback has been massive and has really
impacted
customer engagement but we want we
haven't really seen that in the
workplace what we see is
here's an annual engagement survey fill
it in because your boss tells you to
but actually what's what's it actually
saying and what's
what's the impact of this so we really
wanted to
kind of you know you know evolve the
engagement survey to something that was
very much
a better user experience much more
engaging for employees and actually
enabled them to provide continual
anonymous feedback on things like the
culture
things like inclusion things like how
they're experiencing
you know the workplace things like
what's motivating them and what's
incentivizing them things like are they
happy with their compensation so we're
bringing a culture of continuous
feedback
to employees to workplaces and we're
using that data
to help companies drive an engagement
strategy so rather than saying this is
what i think
our employees want it's actually coming
from the employees but it's coming
in a much more engaged way so
traditionally
you know normal engagement surveys
probably are only going to be completed
by the people in the organization that
are engaged they're not going to be like
by the people that aren't engaged right
sniffing yes fill out that survey and
that's a problem in itself because we're
only getting
10 of the picture so we need to we need
to solve that problem we need to get the
majority
the vast majority of the organization
engaging in these
you know opportunities to provide
feedback so that can really navigate a
targeted engagement plan that can help
people become happier more engaged
more productive and actually stay for
longer and there's a huge
um cost benefit in that for an
organization because it's hugely costly
to leap to lose people
and it's hugely costly to hire them
again so
again the value proposition is you know
the happier and more engaged your people
are the longer they're going to stay the
longer they're going to be committed
and you know our proposition from really
having a
just like a customer engagement strategy
we need an employee engagement strategy
and it's super important
right and i think you're obviously able
to please actually now because of
lockdown because it's very democratized
now we're all at home with our laptops
we don't have fancy canteens we don't
have pool tables we don't have all the
all the bells and whistles right so what
are our organizations really doing
and so how do you actually build the
trust with the employees to be
truthful because i mean the really
interesting pieces of information here
are the ones that are that employees
might feel uncomfortable sharing with
their
managers with with the ceo right i mean
i'm guessing that part of the problem is
that
people aren't communicating and in the
right times right when an employee
sees that something is bothering them or
something is wrong then they don't
immediately necessarily go and report it
they let it you know sit there wallow in
it and then eventually they say okay i'm
just not happy about this because it
hasn't changed
well obviously it hasn't changed because
nobody talked about it
and obviously i'm sure that some do talk
about it but what i'm hearing from you
is that the problem you're solving is
this communication problem
and providing this these data points to
the decision makers
so that they can simply adapt they can
know what's happening
on the floor of on the ground floor of
the company
yeah it's almost as if you know we're
creating this kind of continual response
like how are we doing
because you know you can have a really
bad week and then you can have a really
great week so
having an annual survey or having like a
bi-annual
survey it's not really doing anything by
the time you collect the data
it takes you six months to analyze it
and then you've got a plan to execute
probably half your team have left or
people that were really disengaged and
looking for other jobs
so we need to be we need to close the
gap between
signal to response what are your
employees signaling about your culture
that needs to change like
quicktime how can we pull back people
that are kind of going into that because
you know
when you start a company and you're on
boarding you know you're really happy
you're engaged you're having
but then somewhere along the line you
know the engagement starts
to lag and this is across the board i
think you know globally only like 15 to
20 percent of employees are like highly
engaged so
that organizations face these challenges
but but
where there isn't enough data like quite
rightly say is and when this
sort of thing starts to happen and what
what things like sometimes it could be
changed sometimes it could be you know
that
people are going on lockdown and now
they feel well you know what what's to
say what's to make me you know go
to work for a competitor because you
know now i haven't got the canteen or i
haven't got the
drinks on friday you know what's keeping
me here
so i think there's a lot to say about
the way that we collect data how quickly
we collect it and not only just
collecting it for collecting it's safe
because that's another frustrating thing
about
you know feedback tools it's about
having an engagement plan so we support
companies to create you know engagement
plans that actually they can act upon
and actually you know be able to make
positive and actionable change
and i think when employees start to see
that it will completely shift the
culture
so there's a whole life cycle here that
we're tackling not just the data
collection
but the actual actionable change and
then we actually enable them to monitor
the impact of those changes
on retention and engagement so there's
we're looking at the whole life cycle
so that we we should see change we
should be able to see much more
you know higher levels of engagement and
you know
again trust and authenticity
and high levels of response from
employees we want you know the least
engaged to be
actively you know giving feedback um and
we want you know
there to be this kind of whole level of
transparency that i think
you know in some companies they've
managed it but we've still got a lot of
work to do
amazing paris i want to thank you for
being so generous with your time this
was a
wonderful i really really appreciate it
i think that you're touching on a
problem that is just growing
and there aren't enough people that are
dealing with it and i'm very happy that
you are
and i think that it's it's extremely
worthwhile and i think it's extremely
complicated
and i can't wait to see where we love
work goes so thank you very much for
coming to speak with me
before we leave out to ask for the most
important question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
oh three words um loyal very loyal
um i am
[Music]
committed and
i am i think i'm a happy person
i love that i love that paris thank you
so so much
and stay safe and stay healthy yeah you
too thanks for having me
of course
[Music]
you